PENALTY, JOHN SOLOMON EDITOR IN
CHIEF JUST THE NEWS.COM.
JOINING ME NOW THE ATTORNEY FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP LINDSEY HALLIGAN
IS WITH US.
I WANT TO SPECIFICALLY, ARE
THERE OTHER ITEMS YOU CAN NAME
BESIDES THE PASSPORTS THAT WERE
TAKEN THAT SHOULD NEVER HAVE
BEEN TAKEN?
>> THAT'S THE THING.
WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY
TOOK.
WE'VE ASKED MULTIPLE TIMES FOR A
REAL INVENTORY, A DESCRIPTION OF
WHAT WAS TAKEN.
BUT THE INVENTORY LIST THEY GAVE
US IS BORDERLINE WORTHLESS.
IT DOESN'T SAY WHERE THE
DOCUMENTS WERE LOCATED, WHAT
SPECIFICALLY WAS TAKEN.
NOW WE KNOW THEY SEIZED HIS
PASSPORTS, TWO OF WHICH WERE
EXPIRED, AND THEY GAVE THEM TO
HIS ATTORNEYS TODAY.
SO HE'LL HAVE THEM SOON.
BUT WE HAVE REAL CONCERNS IN
TERMS OF WHETHER THEY WERE RIGHT
TO TAKE CERTAIN THINGS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS NOT
COMMUNICATING WITH US AS TO WHAT
THE EVIDENCE IS AND WHAT THEIR
INTENTIONS ARE, BUT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO TRY TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
CLEARLY HAS DIFFERENT RULES FOR
DONALD TRUMP THAN ANYONE ELSE
OUT THERE.
THE WHOLE SYSTEM TRULY DOES
SUFFER WHEN THEY WRITE DIFFERENT
RULES FOR DIFFERENT PEOPLE.
>> Sean: WHY WERE YOU AND
ANOTHER ATTORNEY OF THE
PRESIDENT DENIED ACCESS TO WATCH
WHAT WAS GOING ON, AND WHO
SPECIFICALLY WERE THEY ASKING TO
TURN OFF THE SURVEILLANCE
FOOTAGE?
>> THEY DIDN'T GIVE US A REASON
FOR PREVENTING US FROM GOING
INSIDE THE PROPERTY.
I EVEN TRIED TO GET IN THE
PROPERTY JUST FOR SAKE OF AIR
CONDITIONING BECAUSE IT WAS LIKE
95 DEGREES OUTSIDE, AND THEY
WERE THERE FROM 10:00 A.M. TO
6:30, I THINK.
BUT THEY WOULDN'T EVEN LET ME
STAND INSIDE THE PROPERTY WHERE
THEY WEREN'T SEARCHING.
THEY ASKED PRESIDENT TRUMP, AND
I THINK HIS MANAGERS, TO TURN
OFF THE SURVEILLANCE, WHICH THEY
DIDN'T.
>> Sean: RIGHT.
OKAY.
WE A